à l'est de coupure
les combats d'artillerie forage
c'est la région
occupée de louance
les lignes de front est à 8 km
leur artillerie pylône nos villages
alors que les combats se déroulent
là-bas nous avons la rivière au ski
peut-être que les envahisseurs veulent
faire de cette rivière la ligne de front
en septembre 2022 des soldats Ukrainiens
se sont photographiés devant la mairie
de coupiansk libérée pendant les
premiers jours de la contrefensive dans
la région de harkis mais depuis les
Russes n'ont jamais laissé cette ville
en paix
cela fait des mois que coupante et
bombardait dernièrement les tirs se sont
intensifiés
qu'allons-nous devenir il m'a dit un
nouveau barmouth
les autorités municipales ont déménagé
leur bureau dans ce sous-sol en plus des
tirs ils sont la cible d'attaque
informationnelle de la Russie
il protège de fausses informations pour
semer la panique parmi la population
voilà par exemple ils disent que les
autorités de la ville sont en train de
fuir que nous nous barrons
bien sûr quand les gens lisent ça ils
pensent que tout va vraiment mal d'où je
parle
oui c'est dur les Russes renforcent
leurs effectifs et leur matériel
mais on va s'en sortir et petit à petit
on va reconquérir toutes les villes
occupées
en ville les employés municipaux mettent
de l'autre comme pour conjurer la guerre
je ne sais pas si c'était un petit
rentrant ou sortant je ne sais pas les
reconnaître bien sûr nous sommes
inquiets mais il faut bien travailler
jusqu'à présent les Russes n'ont jamais
reconquis une ville reprise par les
Ukrainiens lors de leur contre-offensive
l'an dernier
accoupante ils essayent